today we're not tracking a briefing
there will be briefings throughout other
portions of the week absolutely not an
effort to cut back we're looking at
different ways to showcase this
president leading White House press the
White House press secretary Kaylee
Makani announcing there will not be a
coronavirus task force briefing this
evening for the third day in a row this
after the president on Saturday slammed
the media while calling the briefings
quote not worth the time and effort
since March the president and vice
president Pence have given almost 50
daily press briefings to update the
country on the administration's response
to the pandemic that has killed more
than 53,000 people in the u.s. so dr.
Siegel let's go to you first I think
that these briefings have been enormous
ly helpful in giving the American people
information and I don't think that the
the social distancing would have been as
successful without them updating people
every day to explain the data that was
coming in and showing people the results
of what they were doing what do you
think about that Katie I completely
agree with your points not to mention
the devastation to the US health care
system especially in hot spots areas
that have cost hospitals hundreds of
millions of dollars and focusing also on
the response health care workers
response trying different treatments how
patients are doing all of this being
brought to the spotlight and it isn't
just the president talking the taskforce
includes people like dr. Tony Fauci
who's been a top fire ologist in this
country for many many years infectious
disease and dr. Burks as well and dr.
Redfield to run CDC all of these people
coming to the mic and informing the
American public hugely important the
issue is though unfortunately a lot of
this information gets politicized gets
banded about in the media like it's some
kind of contact sport that is so deeply
disturbing one mistake and I'm not
saying mistakes haven't been made big
ones have been made obviously but the
idea that people are waiting in the
wings to take this information attack
the president or other people in the
task force is not helping in the fight
against this virus you know lera early
on it was there was an argument that was
that the political reporters in the
White House press corps should be
replaced with health care reporters that
did not happen and it's and people argue
that maybe we get more relevant
information and questions because as the
doctor just pointed out a lot of the
questions that have been asked over the
50 briefings that we've had weren't
always so focused on the pandemic at
hand
well how about you just replace those
reporters with ones who actually don't
have such a hatred for the President and
such a history and record of hostility
in all of their interactions and their
reporting you're coming from
publications who's reporting on this
president and this administration is 99
or a hundred percent negative a hundred
percent of the time and that's the
context in which these briefings are
taking place and if you look at what the
president tweeted himself he said you
know why why am i boosting their ratings
with fake news but when they're only
hostile and not reporting the facts now
from the reporter's point of view you
know obviously a lot of journalists and
and people would push back against that
especially ones who and there is of
course a need to be critical of the
administration and the president and to
examine these things in detail but the
realities here is that it's not
happening without a history and a
context and you know nobody's fooled by
that so I mean just ask anyone out there
right if they don't like Trump and they
hate Trump they're cheering the
reporters and if they and if they're in
the middle and they really want to know
what's happening with this virus and
they're open-minded or they support the
president then they're frustrated that
these reporters are not giving him a
chance to speak or that I mean still if
this president is as someone who is
unpredictable he's been unpredictable
from the start so just because there's
not one briefing or a week without
briefings doesn't mean they won't resume
again no but we don't know what's gonna
happen any time I hear a reporter or a
news organization putting people out
there who gonna tell you what the
president is thinking and doing unless
they got it from the President himself
I don't believe it because they've all
been wrong almost all the time so
Melissa you know what do you think about
the White House's reasoning here and in
that they want to spend time on other
things and it is true that while
President Trump is the most
very accessible three-hour briefings
over the past two months but that does
leave a lot of room for making mistakes
while you're receiving new information
first of all I can't believe he kept it
up this long I mean this president it
shocks me every day the amount of energy
and stamina he has I don't think any of
the rest of us can keep up with him and
I have no idea how he does it we
couldn't stand there for hours and hours
every day I know I couldn't I think it
had to end at some point and it makes
sense for it to have it now because we
are seeing this dizzy we're seeing the
curve flatten I mean we're seeing the
seriousness of this or or maybe you know
the new territory recedes so now it's we
know what we're dealing with people have
been inside it feels like we are not out
of the woods and I don't mean to imply
that in any way but it does feel like
we've turned a corner and we're getting
closer to opening things back up all
around the country so it's a perfectly
logical time it did get to the point
where reporters were we're going into
gotcha mode and but they're always going
to do that I mean that's just that's
sort of the nature of the beast this
time it's more exaggerated than in the
past but this is a totally different
president